bonsoir et bienvenue ravi de vous
retrouver dans çavau regarde ce soir la
création d'un nouveau journal en France
la tribune dimanche se lance en kiosque
ce weekend bonsoir sois et Kem bonsoir
vous êtes l'un des piliers de cette
nouvelle aventure rédactrice en chef
vous allez tout nous dire du projet de
la ligne éditoriale de l'actionnaire des
exemplaires du prix vous serez rejoint
tout à l'heure dans la deuxème partie
par Bruno jeudi le big boss le directeur
de la rédaction de ce nouvel
hebdomadaire notre grand débat ce soir
comment diminuer le niveau de violence
dans l'espace numérique c'est l'objectif
ambitieux du projet de loi débattu dans
l'hémicycle le texte s'attaque P Mael au
cyber arcellement au sites
pornographiques et aux arnaques en ligne
mais euh bizarrement renonce à lever
l'anonymat sur internet alors pourquoi
nous en débattrons dans un instant avec
mes invités enfin nos affranchis ce soir
le billet du humeur de l'avocat Bertrand
Perrier le mot de la semaine de Mariette
dariggrand et puis action planète la
nouvelle chronique écolo de la Falco
voilà pour le programme on y va SW cam
on y va ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
parti sécurisé et régulé l'espace
numérique c'est donc
l'ambitieux objectif du projet de loi
porté par Jean-Noël barreau est débattu
depuis une semaine dans l'émx un
objectif de taille c'est vrai mais face
au tsunami de haine et de fake news qui
se déverse tous les jours sur les
réseaux sociaux le législateur en a-t-il
vraiment les moyens la loi du monde
physique peut-elle s'appliquer au monde
numérique c'est votre formule vous y
croyez Paul midi bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes le rapporteur de ce
texte vous avez renoncé à vos
amendements sur la levée de l'anonymat
dans l'hémicycle alors que vous étiez
majoritaire vous nous dit Dirz pourquoi
vous êtes député renaissance de lessonne
vous débattez ce soir avec Aurélien
taché bonsoir député écologiste du
valdoise bonsoir Delphine Sabatier ravi
de vous retrouver journaliste Aby Smart
et chroniqueuse dans cette émission sur
les questions numériques enfin bonsoir
maître Gérard as bienvenue vous êtes
avocat spécialiste en droit du numérique
sois kemire la journaliste ou la maman
que vous êtes à sans doute des questions
à soumettre à nos invités n'hésitez pas
à réagir alors qu'est-ce qu'il contient
ce projet de loi les principales mesures
on va d'abord voir cela dans le chrono
de Blacko qu'on accueille tout de
suite bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Miriam
bonsoir à toutes et tous Stéphane
blackakovski que contient ce projet de
loi alors c'est pas pour me trouver les
excuses mais c'est pas facile de résumer
ce de loi ce projet de loi parce que
vous avez dit il était un peu P Mel
c'est vrai qu'il aborde un grand nombre
de sujets d'ailleurs l'opposition
insiste là-dessus en disant que c'est un
petit peu Fourtout malgré tout il y a
quand même une ligne directrice qui est
assez claire protéger au quotidien les
Français contre Ben les dangers
d'Internet alors évidemment quand il
s'agit de tenir tête au tout puissant
géant du numérique la France n'est pas
de taille oui je sais c'est un peu
vexant mais c'est comme ça en revanche
on peut s'appuyer sur l'Union européenne
c'est 450 millions d'habitants qui est
donc plus à même de de tenir tête au
géant du numérique donc deux textes ont
d'ailleurs été adoptés cette année par
les 27 donc je voulais les sites le DMA
c'estàdire une un règlement qui voit
empêcher le monopole des gens du
numérique de permettre aux Européens de
leur faire concurrence donc c'est plutôt
sur l'aspect business et puis le DSA qui
lui plus contrôle concerne plutôt les
contenus qui circulent Surre les réseaux
et les plateformes pour pouvoir les
contrôler un peu mieux et lutter contre
quelques-uns des grands fléos donc vous
sait que un des fléos c'est bien sûr le
harcèlement en ligne donc la France
adapte à partir des règlement européen
des solutions donc dans la loi et bien
désormais lorsqu'un harceleur est
dénoncé il va pouvoir être banni pendant
6 mois des réseaux des plateformes qui
existait déjà mais c'est 6 mois cette
fois-ci préventif c'estàdire avant une
décision de justice on veut faire plus
vite pour mieux protéger les victimes
d'ailleurs gabrielal en avait parlé pour
le harcèlement scolaire la semaine
dernière autre fléo auquel ve s'attaquer
la loi c'est bien sûr la fréquentation
des sites porno par les mineurs alors
officiellement les sites porno sont
interdits au moins de 18 ans sauf
qu'aujourd'hui on voit dans les études
que plus de 80 % des mineurs ont été
confrontés déjà à des images
pornographique donc pour faire respecter
cette interdiction c'est un peu le même
principe on donne la possibilité à
l'administration sans passer par la
justice de bloquer les sites porno qui
laisseraient entrer les mineurs sur sur
leur site c'est l'explication que donne
Jean-Noël Barot notre ministre du
numérique si le le l'arcom le gendarme
de l'audiovisuel de l'Internet peut
bloquer ces sites en quelques semaines
seulement alors sous la pression ils
finiront bien par respecter nos lois et
vérifier de le utilisateurs alors il y a
malgré tout un petit bémol à cette idée
c'est que l'Australie a eu exactement la
même idée mais qu'elle a fini renon par
renoncé au mois d'août parce que n'avait
pas les moyens techniques pour faire
respecter cette interdiction alors
est-ce que les Français sont plus malins
que les Australiens j'ai envie de le
croire mais c'est même pas sûr parce
qu'en fait dans le domaine du numérique
il faut toujours des solutions
techniques efficaces pour faire
respecter la loi je vous prends un
exemple pour lutter contre les arnaques
sur internet au mois de février le
ministre du numérique avait prévu un
filtre anti-arnaque on écoute l'argument
je travaille actuellement au
développement d'un filtre anti-arnaque
un filtre anti-arnaque qui
préviendra préventivement l'internaute
ou l'usager lorsqu'il s'apprête à se
diriger vers un site qui a été identifié
comme un site arnaque alors là le bémol
sur ce site antiarnaque c'est qu'il
était censé être prêt avant la Coupe du
monde de rugby et puis finalement il
était pas au point donc ça sera plutôt
avant les gios si bien sûr il est prêt
mais au-delà de ces difficultés
techniques qui sont sont importante
parce que pour faire respecter la loi il
faut maîtriser cette technique le
principal reproche que font les
opposants à ce texte c'est que sous
prétexte de renforcer la surveillance et
de renforcer les contrôles on finisse
par espionner tout le monde quit à
ressembler à des pays auxquels on ne
veut pas ressembler on écoute un élu du
rassemblement national qui nous fait
part de ses craintes en d'autres termes
vous demandez aux réseaux sociaux
d'assumer le flicage des Français à
votre place c'est inacceptable vous avez
perdu l'esprit
enfin les seuls pays qui ont réussi à
bannir l'anonymat sont des régimes
autoritaires comme la Chine est-ce donc
là réellement un modèle dont vous
souhaitez vous inspirer bon on n est pas
encore au cas de la Chine mais en voilà
le débat est ouvert tout le monde est
d'accord pour stopper les Arnac tout le
monde est d'accord pour stopper le
harcèlement je pense qu'on est d'accord
aussi pour interdire l'accès des mineurs
au site porno mais comment le faire sans
espiner tout le monde alors là et ben on
y va merci pour cette présentation très
claire Stéphane Paul midi on a compris
il y a beaucoup de choses dans ce texte
on va se concentrer déjà sur sur le
cyberhcèlement évidemment parce que
l'actualité nous y ramène et les
suicides récents on peut citer Nicolas
on peut citer lins nous nous invite les
Français nous invitent à trouver des des
solutions le bannissement des réseaux
sociaux c'est la mesure un peu bazooka
contre les cyberhceleurs expliquez-nous
exactement ça veut dire quoi et à quel
moment on peut décider ça avec sans le
juge précisément alors ce qu'on essaie
de faire dans ce texte c'est de pas
monter le fil et couperé le beurre mais
d'appliquer les règles qu'on a dans la
vie physique à l'Espace Numérique
c'est-à-dire dans l'innet et vous savez
que dans la vie physique si un ex-mi qui
battait son ex-fme par exemple peut être
condamné par le le juge à une peine
d'éloignement il n'a pas le droit de se
rendre dans telle ville ou tel
département pendant une durée de donnée
et ben sur internet ça doit être pareil
et donc dans le cas du cyberharcèlement
un cyberhceleur qui est condamné par le
juge par la justice pour cyberhcèlement
le juge pourra lui infliger une peine
complémentaire c'est-àd le banir des
réseaux sociaux pendant 6 mois s'il est
primau délinquant et 12 mois s'il est en
cas de récidif donc ça c'est quand il y
a un un juge on est bien d'accord donc
faut avoir porter plainte et on connaît
le temps de la justice il est très très
long et donc le cyberhcelleur peut sous
un autre compte continuer récidiver
qu'est-ce qu'on fait contre ça alors
juste pour la partie peine de bissement
on ça été annoncé par le gouvernement la
semaine dernière on va aussi proposer
par les amendements en séance de le
mettre en cas contrôle judiciaire
c'estàd que le juge quand il est saisi
d'une affaire avant de l'avoir jugé il
peut éventuellement décider de bannir le
cyberhceleur présumé de des réseaux
sociaux s'il y a un cas de violence
imminente par exemple s'il faut que la
victime soit protégée d'une façon
imminente avant d'attendre le procès ça
c'est pour répondre à votre point après
qu'est-ce qu'on cherche à faire quand on
lutte contre cyberharcelllement dans ce
texte on y va à toutes les étapes du
sujet un c'est l'éducation euh on va
former tous nos jeunes à partir de la 6e
à l'Espace Numérique quels sont les
dangers et notamment le cyberharcèlement
qu'est-ce que c'est comment on le
prévient on va former les parents on va
former les professeurs un l'éducation de
on va responsabiliser les plateformes
c'est l'application du DSA qui a été
mentionné par votre chroniqueur juste
avant où on donne demandant de la
régulation c'est ça on donne une
responsabilité beaucoup plus forte aux
plateformes de modérer les contenus et
si elle ne le modère pas suffisamment on
va les taper au portefeuille la
Commission européenne pourra leur donner
une amende jusqu'à 6 % du chiffre
d'affaires mondial de ces grandes
platformes à quel moment ça on arrive à
6 % on arrive à 6 % quand on fait
n'importe quoi mais malheureusement il y
a des plateformes aujourd'hui qui font
n'importe quoi et on va et on va
responsabiliser les auteurs les
cyberarceleur c'est la peine de
manissement que vous avez mentionné mais
c'est aussi une amende qu'on a mis en
place en commission pour que la police
puisse elle-même se saisir de cas euh et
infliger des
AM avant que le juge soit saisi et si et
même sans que la victime euh ait déposé
plainte parce que le problème dans le
cyberharcèlement c'est que dans la très
grande majorité des cas les gens qui
sont cyberhcelés ils ne déposent pas
plainte soit parce que ils ont honte de
ça soit parce qu'ils savent pas comment
le système marche et donc il faut que la
police et aussi les moyens d'agir d'une
façon proactive alors on va voir si elle
a les moyens d'agir euh partons sur le
terrain avec vous maître as vous vous
défendez des victimes de cyberhcèlement
absoléent c'est une c'est un fléo c'est
un fléo et on et on voit jusqu'où il
peut il peut aller euh elle porte
plainte combien de temps met la justice
à instruire les dossiers jusqu'à la
sanction pénale
alors c'est un fléau et c'est un
parcours du combattant parce que souvent
le cyberhceleur est anonyme si on l'a
identifier c'est pas du tout le même
parcours parce que là on peut porter
plainte et puis la justice peut se
saisir et c'est quand même facile ce qui
est compliqué c'est quand en fait vous
avez des attaques qui viennent partout
sur les réseaux et on sait pas qui a
émis le message mais à supposer qu'on
puisse savoir qui a émis le message et
si c'est un mineur on a encore un autre
problème c'est que les parents ne
voudront pas le mineur est responsable
sous l'autorité des parents les parents
ne voudront pas intervenir et et faire
effacer les contenus donc vous voyez il
y a tout un c'est un il y a un
problématique il y a une problématique
psychologique mais cette idée par
exemple que la police encore faut-elle
qu'elle a les moyens puisse dissuader
par des amendes financières l'auteur de
l'injure du ement est-ce que est-ce que
ça ça pourrait être efficace sans avoir
à déposer plainte en fait sans aller
jusqu'à attendre des procédures longues
de de la justice ça voudrait dire que on
se met dans un système de contravention
ouais et que donc ça dev la loi le
prévoit et cetera ça peut être dissuasif
ça peut être dissuasif de toute façon
dans dans dans là-dessus à partir moment
on identifie la personne la
continvention est dissuasive c'est un
mais là il faut qu'il y a même une
autorisation de la loi ça ça ne peut pas
se faire automatiquement il y a un point
de taché on voit bien que la place du
juge le temps de la justice est centrale
dans cette affaire si on a des des
officiers de police qui surveillent le
net alors je sais pas si c'est avec la
plateforme Faros comment les
signalements si on a les moyens de faire
ça par la police les amendes dissuasives
une première sanction sans attendre la
justice c'est du bon sens non sur cet
aspect là on n pas forcément nous de de
difficulté il a il y a d'autres aspects
dans le texte où effectivement le fait
de de mettre le juge de côté et de faire
appel à des autorités administratives
mais on reviendra peut-être après nous
pose un certain nombre de questions mais
pour revenir sur globalement le le débat
du cur harcèlement effectivement les
mesures qui sont prévues dans le texte
un certain nombre vont dans le bon sens
on a moi je fais parti d'un groupe
parlementaire où j'ai beaucoup de de de
collègues qui sont sans cesse harcelés
beaucoup souvent des collègues femmes je
pense à sonous mais je pour en citer
d'autres moi même il m'arrive d'être
très très violemment attaqué sur les
réseaux sociaux et on se doute bien pour
nos concitoyens qui sont pas élus c'est
encore
autre chose donc la peine de
bannissement on la trouve intéressante
je suis d'ailleurs content d'entendre
que dès le moment du du du contrôle de
la procédure avant que le jugement ait
lieu le bannissement pourra peut-être
être opéré parce que c'était une
proposition d'un collègue sénateur
écologiste donc ne savis pas le
rapporteur général aller donner un avis
favorable mais le le seule petite
difficulté qu'on a nous par exemple
quand on reprend ces sujets qui pourrai
faire consensus je on en a souvent parl
en commission c'est qu'après on a
toujours tendance quand on est dans la
majorité au gouvernement à vouloir tirer
le fil éendre et donc la peine de
bannissement là elle est prévue pour le
cibhcèlement mais aussi prévu pour tout
un tas d'autres sujets vous rappelez
peut-être qu'au moment qui avait suivi
les les émeutes il y avait eu cette idée
de que le gouvernement puisse couper les
réseaux sociaux on va dire pour aller
vite le gouvernement il a renoncé mais
la peine de bannissement là telle
qu'elle est prévue dans le texte n'est
pas uniquement pour le CIB harcèlement
elle est prévue pour tout un tas
d'autres sujets et et ben par exemple le
fait de participer à un on a eu cet
exemple je le donne parce qu'il est
parlant un un appelé un attroupement
avec des armes alors on se dit bah oui
évidemment on va pas laisser passer ça
sauf que la justice aujourd'hui
considère parfois qu'une casserole est
une arme par destination suivez mon
regard il est arrivé récemment que des
manifestations VO voyez ce que je veux
dire voilà j'ai une petite différence
avec raorur général je ne souhaite pas
forcément qu'on cale le monde numérique
sur le monde physique parce que le monde
physique est un monde où les libertés
reculent sans cesse en ce moment et si
le monde numérique pouvait être un
espace où certes on ne fait pas
n'importe quoi je viens de dire qu'on
était favorable à un certain nombre de
mesures mais où la liberté était un peu
préservée je trouve que ce serait quand
même bien aussi dphine sabati on va
parler de l'anonymat dans un instant
mais les plateformes en fait on revient
toujours à ça les plateformes vont-elles
jouer le jeu ou pas là on les tape au
porte-monnaie très fort si elles font
vraiment rien et en même temps on leur
demande systématiquement d'enlever soit
les contenus soit carrément les les
comptes en eux-mêmes quand on sait que
la haine c'est ça le carburant des
réseaux on peut leur faire confiance
même avec la loi B ce qu'on voit c'est
que les bannissements les plus
spectaculaires de ces derniers mois et
ces dernières années ont été décidé par
les plateformes elles-mêm donc en fait
c'est indispensable de créer une vraie
coopération avec ces plateformes on peut
pas faire sans
ellequbook je pense à Donald Trump
typiquement qui a été
ban réseaux sociaux y compris sur
Facebook il y a eu une coordination on
peut citer Kenny West les plateformes
parfois prennent cette décision
elles-même de bannir donc ça veut dire
déjà qu'on sait bannir donc ça c'est un
premier bon point c'est que si l'Europe
de demande à s'exécuter la plateforme
peut pas dire on ne sait pas faire ils
savent très bien le faire euh mais ça ne
fonctionnera que si elle elle joue le
jeu et pour ça ça prend du temps enfin
j'imagine Paul midi que vous en êtes
conscient hein mais c'est une
négociation et il y a un rapport de
force qui se crée avec l'arrivée du
règlement le DSA euh mais ça prend du
temps ça prend du temps pourquoi parce
que eux disent au fond on a une marrée
de messages mondial sur nos réseaux on
peut pas même avec beaucoup beaucoup
par par sont pas du tout sur les mêmes
idéologies que
nous c'estàd en matière de liberté
d'expression aujourd'hui on n'a pas les
mêmes règles que les plateformes c'est
une question de conception de ce que
c'est sur les contenus illicites sur les
contenus illicites le DSA propose une
solution à partir du moment où il y a
des contenus qui sont considérés comme
étant illicites vous le signalez à la
plateforme et c'est gelé en revanche en
matière de cyberhcèlement le problème
c'est un c'est toute une série de
personnes qui se s'attaque à une autre
personne et il faut encore le qualifier
et donc c'est et des fois il y a aussi
et on est avec une population aussi qui
est indigné donc la le c'est la personne
qui ressent que c'est un cyber
harcèlement mais il faut encore le
qualifier donc c'est voyez il y a un
problème là-dessus où on peut pas de
facto le dire sinon on fait une censure
donc voyez c'est c'est là où ça devient
compliqué là-dessus il a il y a aussi
des solutions technologique moi c'est
mon registre donc je vais parler de ça
mais il y a des solutions de détection
des contenus qui permettraient d'arriver
beaucoup plus tôt au début du cas de
harcèlement à la fois l'intelligence
artificielle les études linguistiques
sur les textes les données les mots qui
reviennent c'est ça mais il y a de plus
en plus aussi de harcèlement via l'image
via les photos les montages vidéos et ça
aujourd'hui il faut mettre en place ces
technologie il faut se donner les moyens
aussi hein d'agir très très vite sur ces
sur ces contenus alors un moyen d'agir
et on y vient àos à vos amendements
c'était de lever l'anonymat c'est vrai
qu'il y a une demande sociale très forte
on l'entend monter alors pourquoi
pourquoi vous n'avez pas réussi à mettre
en place ce que vous souhaitiez
c'est-à-dire une immatriculation
numérique obligatoire pour entrer sur
les réseaux sociaux et pour lutter
contre un sentiment d'impunité ça
demande une petite explication je vous
donne la parole juste après ce sujet
signé
lesos après la carte d'identité et le
passeport voici leur équivalent virtuel
la carte d'identité numérique
pour certifier son identité en ligne
pour l'heure elle servira d'abord à
sécuriser l'accès aux services
administratifs sur Internet la loi
prévoit sa généralisation d'ici 2027 100
% accessible gratuitement et pas de
caractère obligatoire évidemment pour
cette identité numérique mais près de
200 députés dont le macroniste Paul midi
voulait s'en servir pour aller beaucoup
plus loin et en faire un outil de lutte
contre le cyberhcèlement l'idée obliger
les utilisateurs des réseaux sociaux à
certifier leur compte via leur identité
numérique la justice pourra donc
remonter jusqu'à l'usager grâce à un
code de quoi mettre fin au sentiment
d'impunité qui règne sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est en tout cas l'AVE de son
auteur ce qu'on propose c'est tout
simplement d'appliquer les principes qui
marchent dans la vie physique à l'Espace
Numérique et ce principe il est très
clair c'est oui au pseudonymat non à
l'anonymat le problème c'est le niveau
de violence sur les réseaux sociaux la
cause numéro 1 c'est le sentiment
d'anonymat sur les réseaux sociaux qui
génère un sentiment d'impunité qui fait
que pour beaucoup d'entre nous il n'y a
plus de limite mais l'outil ne fait pas
l'unanimité aujourd'hui le problème ce
n'est pas la question de l'anonymat ou
des réseaux sociaux c'est la diffusion
même à visage découvert de la parole
homophobe de paroles sexistes et de
paroles racistes c'était des amendements
qui un ne permettai en rien de de
déconstruire l'ensemble de ses paroles
racistes sexistes et homophobes mais qui
était en danger pour l'ensemble des
militants les militants pour les droits
humains et pour les militants écologiste
retiré par son auteur la mesure ne verra
finalement pas le jour mais elle aura
relancé le débat sur l'anonymat en ligne
une question cruciale dans la lutte
contre le cyberhcèlement Paul midit ce
qu'il faut ajouter à à ce sujet c'est
que vous étiez majoritaire dans
l'hémicycle sur ces amendements hier
soir et ça c'est incompréhensible
majoritaire vous n'êtes pas allé au vote
alors je va pourquoi vous vous êtes
débiné vous expliquer effectivement
c'était déjà une démarche collective on
était près de 200 députés à cossigner
ces amendements et faire cette
proposition qui est de dire oui au
psodyat non à l'anonymat comme ça a été
très bien expliqué dans votre sujet on
est on est passé en à l'Assemblée hier
soir sur ce sujet on était largement
majoritaire pour autant euh le
gouvernement vous a empêché pas du tout
les opposition certaines oppositions
nous ont fait part de leur réticence à
ce sujet et nous ont dit en fait fait
très clairement si vous faites passer
cette mesure nous voterons contre le
texte et donc en responsabilité on a
décidé collectivement d' d'enlever ces
amendements parce que derrière on ne
voulait pas risquer de ne rien avoir
c'est-à-dire de ne même pas avoir ni les
mesures anonymat ni le texte complet sur
cette loi de sécurisation de l'espace
numérique donc toutes les mesures de
cyberhcèlement de lutte contre les
arnaques de lutte contre l'exprion en
gros vous vouliez obligé à avoir un un
code indéchiffrable par les plateformes
mais par administration qui vous
immatricule à chaque fois que vous allez
sur les réseaux ouai et donc donc on a
on a fait le choix de préserver la
capacité à faire voter le texte et on a
retiré même si je le dis on était
majoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale pour
voter ces amendements et je pense qu'on
est majoritaire de loin dans la société
dans le pays pour faire passer ce sujet
on est en majorité relative si on avait
été en majorité absolue elle serait
passée mais on est en majorité relative
donc on en tire les cons parce que le
ministre chargé du numérique Jean-Noël
défendait cette mesure il en parlait
beaucoup à tous les journalistes qui
recevaient est-ce que l'idée c'est que
ça revienne d'une façon ou d'une autre
je sais pas d'ici 2 mois 3 mois 1 an
est-ce est-ce que vous dites ça ça
arrivera un jour ou bien on n arrive pas
de toute façon là vous êtes en majorité
relative et d'ici la fin du kquena c'est
vous laisserez ça de côté non on est au
début de l'histoire début du combat ça
fait 10 ans qu'on est massivement dans
les réseaux sociaux 80 % des Français
sont sur les réseaux sociaux donc on est
au tout début de l'histoire de la
régulation et c'est le Far West
aujourd'hui mais comme c'était le Far
West au début des États-Unis et puis
après on met des règles on met de
l'ordre et puis on vit tous bien en
communauté donc c'est le début on y
reviendra et en particulier dans
quelques mois c'est la campagne des
européennes et votre ch dire que
l'Europe aussi s'est penchée sur le
sujet forcment la mê manre dit c'est que
face aux plateformes internationales
c'est en européen qu'on est le plus fort
pour leur votre programme c'est ça alors
on fait effectivement partie des groupes
parlementaires qui qui peuvent soutenir
ce texte mais qui n'auraiit certainement
pas voté si ces dispositions av en
faisait partie pourquoi ça peut paraître
une bonne idée effectivement comme ça de
de lever l'anonyat mais d'abord je
rappelle que encore une fois et ça a été
rappelé par des des collègues aussi de
la majorité évidemment quand la justice
doit vous interpeller vous devez
répondre devant elle mais quand vous
vous baladez dans la rue quand vous êtes
vous n'êtes pas tenu de mettre votre nom
sur votre veste et et et c'est un peu la
même chose sur Internet et si on regarde
des exemples récents je pense au
journaliste par exemple je pense à cette
journaliste Arian lavriux qui a fait un
travail exceptionnel sur sur l'opération
Cly avec disclose si elle n'avait pas pu
enquêter vraiment de manière anonyme sur
le web si il y avait pas un certain
nombre de dispositions qui protégeent la
vie privée et l'anonymat sur Internet il
y a beaucoup de choses qu'on ne pourrait
plus faire ou dire aujourd'hui et donc
c'est vrai qu'on fait partie de ceux qui
qui se sont opposés à cette à cette
partie du texte mais si j'en crois euh
euh vous parlez de l'Europe à l'instant
si j'en crois le courrier rendu public
par la presse de Thierry Breton
aujourd'hui on n'est pas les seuls
visiblement à s'inquiéter quand même d'
certain n de M qui aur pu finalement
figurer dans le texte donc je pense que
c'est vraiment de bonne àoi et ça pose
plein d'autres questions vous vous vous
parlez de l'identité numérique dans dans
le sujet on en a parlé hier soir chers
collègues là aussi on n'est pas tout à
fait au point on voit pas exactement
quelle identité numérique vous dont vous
voulez nous parler il y a des gens qui
sont encore dans la fracture numérique
il ne faut pas aller trop vite sur ces
sujets je pense qu'encore une fois les
principes de liberté qui sont
aujourd'hui ceux sur Internet ne doivent
pas permettre de faire n'importe quoi et
la justice doit pouvoir agir mais
attention à la
société solutionisme technolog c'était 2
ans pour se mettre en route jusqu'en
2027 où ce sera obligatoire moi ce qui
m'intéressefine Sabatier vous avez fait
une chronique ici pour nous dire ça
n'est c'est ça n'est pas de bon sens de
lever un ANOM qui n'existe pas parce
qu'en fait on peut retrouver toutes les
personnes grâce aux adresses IP mais ce
dont parle Paul mi c'est le sentiment
d'être anonyme et donc le sentiment
qu'il y a une impunité si vous obligez
tout le monde à quelque part montrer PES
blanche est-ce que ça va pas tout
simplement réduire le niveau de violence
pour enlever ce sentiment
euh permissif il faut agir en fait et et
enfin n'importe quel expert de la
cybersécurité vous dira on n pas un
problème d'anonymat aujourd'hui sur
Internet euh à chaque fois qu'il y a une
enquête on sa'est retrouvver qui est
derrière une adresse IP parfois il y a
des choses plus compliquées voilà on a
parlé on on a essayé de faire un peu de
pédagogie avec les VPN par exemple mais
de toute façon on finit par retrouver
par un faisceau d'indice simplement on a
des enquêtes qui peuvent prendre un an 2
ans voilà c'est ça exactement donc euh
ce qu'il faut surtout travailler c'est
les processus opérationnels aujourd'hui
quand on va déposer plainte c'est vrai
qu'il y a pas assez de plainte vous avez
raison mais quand on le fait on va sur
Faros par exemple sur la plateforme
dédiée on appelle le 308 qu'est-ce qui
se passe derrière comment est-ce qu'on
s'assure que le process fonctionne que
c'est opérationnel et puis il faut une
réflexion globale vous dites l'UR est
pas au diapason là-dessus parce qu'on a
déjà longtemps réfléchi autour de ce
règlement le DSA appliquons déjà ce
règlement voyons queles sont les
insuffisances de l'industrie du texte et
ensuite on avance c'est vrai qu'il faut
y aller pas à pas parce que le numérique
ça reste un sujet technique donc il y a
plein de pièges aussi he technique le
l'avocat qu'est-ce qu'il en pense ce
serait un
alors je
par alors je suis parfaitement d'accord
avec ce que dit Delphine et et ce que je
voudrais vous vous expliquer un petit
peu la la position du citoyen
justiciable allez-y d'abord pour moi
c'est pas la le le débat il est pas
autour de de la levée d'anonymat parce
que finalement on a des moyens
aujourd'hui juridiques d'arriver à une
levée d'anonymat le seul problème que
l'on a c'est qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
action pénale qui a été initiée et c'est
à ce moment-là que la justice on a bien
comprisoui le problème c'est que
beaucoup de avant il faut encore le
qualifier être dans le cas d'une
infraction un cyber harcèlement c'est il
faut il faut mettre en place des textes
pour les considè identité numérique
sorte de porte d'entrée sur le net alors
la question et c'est là que c'est
intéressant c'est moins l'anonymat que
l'authentification en fait les
justiciables ce qu'ils ont besoin c'est
qu'ils ont un besoin de savoir qui a dit
quoi pour pouvoir agir et c'est ça le
vrai problème or derrière voilà derrière
l'anonym se cache en fait c'est cette
possibilité de de parcours du comb de
combattant pour arriver à les identifier
pourquoi parce qu'on va revenir à une
adresse IP cette adresse IP il va
falloir demander à un hébergeur qui nous
communique en fait les le nom de de son
abonné il va pas vouloir le faire il va
demander qui une notification et il
faudra faire une ordonnance enfin une
requête judiciaire qui ne pourra être
faite que dans le cas d'un référé d'une
manière contradictoire Internet il est
instantané Absolum et entre temps ça ça
ruisselle ça ruisselle et ça s'implifie
donc c'est c'est un vrai problème
aujourd'hui donc vous savez le jeune il
s'est déjà suicidé hein celui qui est si
bararcelé le
temp personne nessaie de faire alors
Paul mi quand vous vous dites ça on se
dit quand même c'est bizarre vous vous
avez battu en r les 15 jours tous les 15
jours dans notre pays il y a un jeune
qui se suicide siite suite à du
cyberhcèlement ou du harcèlement
scolaire faut prendre conscience du
niveau de violence qu'on a accepté sur
ces réseaux sociaux et il faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose et par rapport aux
arguments sur les questions de liberté
parce que là alors il faut ça
c'est évidemment un très bon débat mais
moi je veux être très clair dans ce
qu'on propose on veut pas toucher un
chouille des libertés ni d'expression ni
d'information pourquoi c'est pour ça que
je je dis bien c'est oui au pseudonyat
non l'anonyma oui au pseudonyat bien sûr
qu'on doit pouvoir avoir autant de
comptes sur facebook qu'on veut et c'est
William 92 avec la photo de de mon chien
ou polo 91 avec la photo de mon chat et
je dois pouvoir m'exprimer sous
pseudonyma d'une façon totalement libre
comme dans la rue j'ai pas besoin de
mettre mon nom sur ma veste je suis sous
pseudonyme
mais c'est pas parce que je peux
m'exprimer sous pseudonyma que si
j'utilise mon compte pour faire quelque
chose de de très illégal comme par
exemple si harceler quelqu'un qui va se
suicider de semaines après je dois pas
pouvoir être retrouvé par la justice
quand je conduis une voiture je mets pas
mon nom dessus mais j'ai j'ai une plaque
d'immatriculation pour bien comprendre
comment ça fonctionnerait cette
immatriculation les réseaux les
plateformes ne pourrait pas vous
retrouver mais ça appartiendrait à qui
l'administration ex en fait c'est très
simple vous avez votre votre identité
numérique sur France identité exactement
comme votre partage l'a monté juste
avant et quand vous voulez créer votre
compte sur Facebook ou vous certifiez
bien il y a une connexion informatique
qui se fait entre Facebook et France
identité et France identité ne renvoie
que deux informations parce qu'on ne
veut pas que Facebook et les cartes
d'identité de tous les Français surtout
pas France identité renvoie deux
informations 1 première information il y
a bien une personne physique derrière ce
compte deuxième information voilà le
code chiffré indéchiffrable qu'on
demande à Facebook de garder dans son
ordinateur mais qui est indéchiffrable
par facebook mais le jour où le compte
est utilisé pour faire quelque chose de
très illégal sous réquisition du juge le
juge demandera à Facebook merci de me
donner le code indéchivrable pour toi
mais que le juge pourra évidemment
déchif c'est qui donne c'est j'entendais
murmurer de ce côté du débat c'est la
Chine vraiment je connais pas d'autres
pays ça mais oui le contrôle social le
scoring après je dis pas que c'est
l'intention oui mais
simpl on arrive à ça et ça va pas
enlever le sentiment d'impunité
puisqu'on aura quand même ce pseudo vous
dites ça vous pouvez en
unut a tellement de choses à faire déjà
aujourd'hui des moyens d'action il faut
donner des moyens à la justice à la
police pour déjà faire appliquer la loi
aujourd'hui derrière les plaintes on n
pas d'action systématique en fait je
pense qu'il faut vous avez raison on
peut en donner plus de moyens c'est plus
50 % de budget qu'on a donné à justice
depuis 6 ans et on a rajouté 15
milliards d'euros au budget de la police
et de la gendarmerie dans la moitié 7
milliards sont sur les enjeux du
numérique pour autant je pense qu'il
faut prendre le sujet dans le bon sens
parce que si on était dans la vie
physique avec une cap d'invisibilité
comme Harry Potter vous imaginez le
niveau de violence qu'on aurait dans la
vie physique on pourrait vous mettre 20
policiers autour de vous trois juges et
et six gendarmes ça changerait pas vous
pensez vous êtes
anonyme anyme pror et donc il faut qu'
qu'on ne se remette pas dans un un
climat de sentiment d'IMA qui crée ce
stim en impunité il faut traiter le
sujet à la
causes vous saz sur
Facebook le mod chinois sur Facebook les
gens sont plutôt sous leur réel identité
parce que c'était le principe et ben le
niveau de violence sur Facebook est
beaucoup moins élevé que par exemple le
niveau de violence sur Twitter les
niveaux de violence des discours sont en
augmentation sur Facebook il y a une
radicalisation parce que les gens sont
dans leur Bull et finalement ils
réaffirment leurs opinions de manière de
plus en plus ostentato c'est aux
plateformes qu'on devrait demander
d'agir làdessus
on était d'accord elles ont des
centaines de milliards de budets es ont
les moyens techniques qu'on les oblige à
faire de la modération qu'on les oblige
par les algorithmes à finalement générer
Mo VI cours en application on peut au
moins se réjouir de ça à 27 on a réussi
à se mettre d'accord pour mettre des des
sanctions puissantes vous voulez le mot
de la fin quelques secondes à peine je
veux dire que ce qui est intéressant
c'est que on voit qu'il y a un problème
de société que on peut pas faire
confiance aux plateformes mais en même
temps il faut faire attention parce que
il faut pas que la sécurité nous prive
de nos libertés et donc effectivement il
faut y aller à petit pas parce que c'est
des gros il y a une grande demande
sociale mais il faut que en fait on on
on l'encadre parce qu'on est dans un
état dé lib l'prit synthèse de l'avocat
pour terminer merci on a fait un premier
pas c'est généralisation de l'identité
numérique d'ici 2027 accessible à tous
et gratuite voilà c'est le premier étage
de la fusée comme vous dites merci
beaucoup merci d'être venu débattre sur
ce plateau vous restez avec moi sois
kemr dans une dizaine de minutes les
parties pris de nous a franchi ce soir
le duo Perrier d'arégrand bien sûr
Bertrand Perrier qui s'est penché sur la
première promotion de sortie de la
nouvelle Enna on a hâte de savoir ce que
ça donne le mot de la semaine de
Mariette d'igrand c'est le mot empathie
et puis de quoi nous parlez-vous dans
Action planète la Falco ce soir on parle
des nouveaux discours antiécolo et en
particulier sur la loisane zéro
artificialisation net ah oui je vois à
tout à l'heure les amis mais d'abord on
va parler de la naissance d'un nouveau
journal le vôtre désoris soisi Kem le
premier numéro de la tribune dimanche
sera dans les kiosques ce dimanche
j'imagine qu'il y a pas mal de stress
c'est un défi la pression monte et Marco
pommier est allé tourner dans dans la
nouvelle rédaction du de la tribune du
dimanche 120000 exemplaires c'est
beaucoup regardez l'invitation et on en
parle avec Bruno jeudi qui nous rejoint
juste après si on vous invite Bruno
jeudi et sois keménner c'est parce que
le compte à rebour est lancé dans moins
de 48 he la tribune dimanche sortira
dans les kiosques et dans les locaux du
journal économique La Tribune la
rédaction est à pied d'œuvre mais
impossible de montrer quoi que ce soit
pas question de voir la une on est
heureux parce que lancer un lancer un
journal en papier en 2023 c'est c'est
inattendu c'est inespéré c'est même un
exploit pour cet hebdomadaire
généraliste monté en 80 jours pas un de
plus et c'est vous qui en prenez la tête
Bruno JEI épaulé par vous keménner votre
duo ne date pas d'aujourd'hui mais de la
grande époque du Journal du Dimanche en
2015 vous partez vers d'autres aventures
Paris Match pour l'un Marianne pour
l'autre cet été on vous retrouve côte à
côte en soutien au gréistes du JDD
contre l'arrivée polémique de geoffroid
le jeune à la tête de la rédaction ce
journaliste marqué à l'extrême droite
direr ce journal pendant 12 ans donc
j'ai
vu ce que c'était que de de de suivre
une ligne éditoriale et cette ligne
éditoriale est s'opposé par ses valeurs
à l'extrême droite en concurrence
directe avec le JDD votre journal
Dominica lui se veut sans couleur
politique on n pas la recherche des
lecteurs on recherche des lecteurs on
est allé à la rencontre des Français en
les interrogeant sur qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent comme quotidien le dimanche et
très majoritairement on nous a répondu
qu'on veut un journal avec position
centrale politique économie écologie art
de vivre sport et culture et bien sûr
des scoupes c'est la promesse éditoriale
de ce journal au format berlinois de 48
pages vendu 2,40 € un tirage ambitieux
120000 exemplaires pour les premiers
numéros 13000 points de vente sur tout
le territoire mais dans un contexte
économique délétaire pour la presse
écrite n'est-ce pas un Paris un peu
fou et merci de nous avoir rejoint br au
JEI bonsoir merci d'être avec nous c'est
donc vous le nouveau directeur de la
rédaction de cette tribune dimanche
c'est vrai que c'est 20000 exemplaire
c'est beaucoup c'est presque les mêmes
tirages du JDD et du Parisien du du
dimanche un peu fou donc ou pas ce Paris
oui forcément il y a un peu de il y a un
peu de folie en 2023 alors que tout le
monde pense que le papier est mort ben
il est pas mort le papier parce qu'en
plus on y croit au papier euh ça fait 10
ans qu'on croit que la presse papier est
annoncée pour morte et en fait on se
rend compte que quand on réfléchit à un
projet éditorial de dominical si on veut
vraiment exister il faut être sur le
papier alors on va
être ce qui est un peu fou dans
l'histoire c'est que la Tribune a fermé
le papier il y a 10 ans et nous 10 ans
plus tard on décide à côté de La
Tribune.fr qui chaque jour est un pur
player économique sur le web et bien le
dimanche on est en version on est en
version papier donc la tribune dimanche
prolongement généraliste de la tribune
journal économique mais là on est
vraiment sur l'ofre ser l'offre sera
généraliste et et et si on ajoute dans
cette folie effectivement parce que le
papier ça veut direindust donc il faut
recréer tous les métiers toute la chaîne
de fabrication d'un journal papier et
samedi soir on SAA si ça marche bah je
vous Souha en tout
cas c'est vrai que bon il y a un peu de
stress c'est normal c'est un gros défi
il y a de la pression c'est allé très
très très vite Christophe Tortora le
président de La Tribune a annoncé le
lancement j'ai regardé à la fin de l'été
c'était le 20 août ça fait 80 jours
c'est bon vous êtes prêt non mais vous
parliez tout à l'heure de Paris fou mais
pourquoi on est tous venus déjà parce
que Bruno nous a appelé moi j'avais eu
la chance de déjà travailler avec Bruno
donc j'ai dit oui très très vite mais on
est venu aussi pour ça quand on est
journaliste on a envie de prendre des
risques on a envie de se réveiller le
matin et de pas savoir où on sera le
soir on a envie de tenter de nouvelles
choses et tenter de nouvelles choses
dans la presse écrite mais c'est un peu
compliqué depuis des années dernier
dernier journal de presse écrite en 2010
enfin il y a 10 ans pardon c'était
l'opinion donc il y a quelque chose d'un
peu d'un peu inattendu dans le fait de
lancer un journal comme celui-là en 2023
un journal qui sera un journal de 2023
parce que vous dis disa tout à l'heure
on a travaillé ensemble au journal du
Grand à la grande époque du
JDD dit mais on va pas faire le JDD de
2010 là on fait un journal de 2023
transformation écologique les
territoires vrai ce sera pas de
retrouver cet esprit JDD quiourd' il va
on va on va essayer de le chercher mais
on va en fait on va essayer d'avoir une
chercher quand même un peu l'é lecteur
déçus non d'aujourd'hui oui bah nous
Jean-Christophe Tortora dans votre sujet
le dit on cherche on cherche des on
cherche pas des électeurs on cherche des
lecteurs oui on cherche des lecteurs et
partout partout on essaiera de les avoir
effectivement il y en a semble-t-il qui
sont un peu déroutés par par l'offre du
la nouvelle offre du du JDD nous on va
reprendre certaines recettes qui ont
bien fonctionné et puis on va en
appliquer des nouvelles avec notre
propre identité sois vient de la
décliner et c'est ce mixte là qu' qu'on
qu'on qu'on imagine faire et on im et on
espère que ça plaira il y a de la place
pour trois acteurs trois journaux le
dimanche à votre avis la publicité à à a
manifestement déjà répondu positivement
très positivement ça c'est bon signe oui
ça c'est bon signe ça c'est le meilleur
signe qu'on pouvait avoir de la part de
la publicité c'est pas suffisant il
faudra des lecteurs il faut des lecteurs
en kiosque aujourd'hui on pense qu'il y
a un marché le dimanche qui est plus
important que qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui
la difficulté c'est les kiosques et ça
c'est vrai que vous êtes pas sûr d'être
en kiosque partout si ben on tire à
120000 justement pour être présent
partout pour qu'on soit connu on n'est
pas connu aujourd'hui nous on arrive on
est outsider donc pour être connu il
faut d'abord qu'on nous voit il faut
qu'on nous voit dans les dans les
boutiques de des vendeurs de journaux
dimanche Partout en Mayenne comme dans
les Alpes de alors il y a déjà une
campagne de pub qu'on peut commencer à
voir sur sur les kiosques mais nous on
fait le pari que notre offre sera forte
euh qu'il y aura des des exclusivités
qui donneront envie allez donnez-nous
envie un petit peu sans dévoiler
vraiment les secrets on parle de
surprise oui forcément pour un dans
quelle rubrique politique en fait sur
tout le journal hein en fait on a essayé
le le numéro on dit toujours avec sois
qu' on sera sans doute plus à l'aise sur
le numéro 2 le numéro 3 parce qu'on sera
un peu libéré le premier on est un peu
obligé de faire attention donc on a
cherché vraiment non on aura on aura des
surprises en politiques on aura des
surprises en en économique et social on
aura des surprises aussi gastronomique
j'ai d gastronomique il y aura une belle
une jolie surprise la une vous l'avez
déjà ou pas il y a une jolie surprise
aussi sur sur la la littérature euh la
une oui on est un petit peu mais vous
savez c'est comme du temps de l'ancien G
a vous avez travaillé guerre au
Parisien on le on le fera samedi donc ça
peut changer ça peut changer tout peut
changer vous avez un casting 5 étoiles
il faut le dire franchement Ludovic
Vigon je suis sûre que ceux qui nous
regardent reconnaissent ses plumes pour
la politique François clémau pour
l'Internationale Anna Cabana pour la la
culture tous ces gens-là on dit oui tout
de suite facile à convaincre ououi oui
moi c'est pour moi ça a été un bonheur
d'appeler les gens qui disent oui et
puis il y a eu des des des rencontres
inattendues François Simon voilà qu'
qu'on sort de sa semi retraite qui vient
écire pour nous ça c'est génial et puis
il y a des collègues du JDD qu'on
récupèreilà c'est aussi un déchirement
on peut pas il y en a beaucoup qui ont
voulu rentrer il a fallu faire un choix
Philippe Vandel qui qui vient faire une
rubrique média assez décoiffante voilà
hebdogénéraliste et ligne centrale
qu'est-ce qu'il faut comprendre ni
droite ni gauche parce que centrale on
peut se dire macroniste de toute façon
il y a des gens qui pensent à gauche des
gens qui pensent à droite oui il y a des
gens qui il y aura des macronises dans
nos dans nos lecteurs moi ça fait 30 un
peu ça fait à peu près 30 ans que je
suis journaliste politique on m'a mis
toutes les on m'a collé toutes les
étiquettes bon certaines c'est vrai que
je les ai pas eu mais en globalement
toutes les étiquettes du bloc central je
les ai eu euh après les gens penseront
ce qu'ils voudront voilà les gens
penseront ce qu'il ils nous connaissent
quand même un petit peu exig et et
moi-même ils nous connaissent un peu
donc oui effectivement on aime bien la
nuance ça c'est vrai on nime pas trop
les extrêmes ça c'est vrai Miriam h et
brun quand il a présenté le journal la
première fois disait quelque chose qui
me plisait beaucoup il disait que
c'était anti buuzz et donc nous l'idée
c'est d'offrir du temps de lecture c'est
que l'idée moi mon rêve c'est que
dimanche matin les gens s'installent
avec un café le journal et qu'ils aient
le temps et qu'ils oublie le temps parce
qu'ils auront énormément de de matière
on sait que les on sait que les lecteurs
aiment de plus en plus lire du long du
des choses qui ont été pensé qui ont été
ciselé j'ai commencé à lire quelques
articles c'est vraiment pas mal il y
aura le les coup d'actu avec des
interviews politiques il y en aura bien
sûr alçon un peu JDD à l'ancienne très
attendu pour lancer la semaine c'est ça
ça m'a toujours paru incroyable on a
reproché une époque de oui le
journal à des à des interviews de de
ministres B non mais pourquoi il aurait
pas d'interview de ministre mais il y a
aussi des interview d'opposants donc
tout ça me paraît vraiment non mais
c'est aussi cette volonté de vouloir
toujours mettre des étiquettes sur je
comprends je comprends le je comprends
totalement le jeu oui des in minist il y
en aura mais quand ils auront quelque
chose à dire h c'est bien compris alors
on connaît assez peu votre actionnaire
le milliardaire francolibanais rodolp
Saad qui a racheté le groupe de
transport maritime CMA CGM est-ce que
vous avez obtenu des garanties
d'indépendance de sa part on vous a vu
sur les images vous avez soutenu les
grevistes du JDD qui à contrecœur ont
quitté leur journal absolument j'ai j'ai
des garanties d'indépendance de la part
de de Rodolph sad d'abord un moi je je
me réjouis totalement que un industriel
un homme un homme d'affaires comme
Rodolf sad décide d'investir dans de la
presse écrite en 2023 je ne comprends
pas les polémiques pe y avoir parfois
autour de des soupçons qui peut y avoir
non moi je trouve que quelqu'un qui
croit dans la presse écrite et on serait
tout de suite soupçonneux je ne
comprendrai pas après je ne suis pas
naïf je suis journaliste politique j'en
ai j'ai été j'ai toujours travaillé dans
le privé j'ai j'ai eu toujours des
patrons privés j'ai eu j'ai j'ai souent
eu des bonnes pioches j'ai eu des très
mauvaises pioches tout le monde le sait
mon histoire est connue j'ai été écarté
licencié d'un de Paris Match après avoir
éid des critiques en inter pour une une
sur le cardinal pour que les gens qui
nous regardent comprennent bien ce
cardinal conservateur donc je me lance
pas dans une nouvelle aventure de de
presse écrite sans avoir un minimum de
de garanti et j'en ai donc voilà grodos
a construit un groupe un groupe média il
a décidé de de marquer le coup avec
cette ce geste de créer la tribune
dimanche ce n'est pas un philanthrope
non plus pour autant mais c'est un geste
fort qui correspond aussi un peu à
l'ambiance du moment c'est-à-dire que
oui effectivement dimanche l'offre est
en train de changer donc nous on amène
on élargit on élargit l'offre bon et
comment vous regardez on est à la Chaîne
Parlementaire ici à l'Assemblée national
tous ces débats sur les états généraux
de l'information il y a même une
proposition de loi transpartisane
Renaissance écologiste LFI pour faire en
sorte que les aides publiques de la
presse soient conditionné à un droit de
véto des journalistes des rédactions sur
la nomination de leur leur directeur de
rédaction après l'affaire geoffro le
jeune au j dit est-ce que ça va dans le
bon sens est-ce que au fond on a besoin
du législateur dans cette crise de la
presse en tout cas on a besoin de
réflexion ça c'est sûr à un moment il
est utile de d'appuyer sur pause de
regarder ce qui se passe de regarder les
quel est le paysage ce qui s'est passé
ce à quoi ont pu être confrontés nos
anciens collègues qui sont des gens
qu'on connaît depuis depuis des années
donc on a regardé évidemment ce qui se
passait cet été après les états généraux
de la presse mais on verra ce qu'il en
sort hein surtout on va surtout prendre
le temps on est journaliste donc on va
passer le temps va prendre le temps de
regarder exactement ce qui se passe de
regarder ce qu'il en sort et là on vous
dira ce qu'on en pense euh les
échos la le monde ont des chares
d'indépendance bien négocié est-ce que
ça devrait devenir le modèle pour vous
Brunau je moi je crois qu'il faut quand
même de la souplesse faut laisser un peu
chaque rédaction quand même trouver le
bon le bon format l'idée du vote est une
idée qu'il faut pas rejeter moi j'ai
longtemps été plutôt opposé à cette idée
là et j'avoue que j'ai évolué avec ce
qui s'est passé notamment au JDD les
échos et puis j'ai vu moi aussi ce qui
s'est passé dans dans des rédactions où
j'ai travaillé je crois qu'il faut
réfléchir à cette question d'ailleurs
pour
laatribune.fr pour la tribune il y a une
décision qui a été prise par
l'actionnaire justement de faire un vote
en cas de changement de directeur de la
rédaction aujourd'hui ça va très bien
pour lui s'appelle Philippe Mabille
c'est notre directeur à soisig et moi
parce que nous sommes intégrés à la
rédaction de La Tribune mais rodolp sad
a accepté le principe d'une
d'un vote sur le en cas de de changement
de directeur de ouz donc ça c'est quand
même c'est c'est c'est bon ça fait
partie de des élément qu'il pose qu'il
pose sur la table dernière question je
sais qu'il y a un ancrage local avec les
équipes de la Provence également vous
avez fait un tour de France oui
qu'est-ce que vous en retirez des des
Français des attentes des lecteurs qu'on
pourrait retrouver dimanche bien je
pense que mon passage à Toulouse a fait
que moi j'ai au début j'étais assez
radical sur deux trois trucs pas de fait
d'hiver ou peu j'étais pas convaincu
qu'il fait du sport tout le monde sait
que j'adore le sport et quand je suis
passé à Toulouse j'ai vraiment une levée
de bouclier assez forte et donc là je on
est rentré on s'est dit il va y avoir
des pages de sport et assurons tout de
suite nos nos téléspectateurs il y aura
deux belles pages de sport notre format
est grand vous l'avez rappelé dès
dimanches et peut-être plus si s'il faut
si la France gagne la coupe du monde de
rugby le 28 le 28 octobre le rugby aura
toute sa place donc par exemple ça j'ai
j'ai plutôt changé changé d'avis en tous
les cas c'était c'était intéressant il y
a il y a d'autres élément on a eu des
discussions parfois un peu chahuté avec
certains certains lecteurs sur le fait
que par exemple nous nous on croit
beaucoup en la science donc moi je suis
pas du tout pour laisser s'exprimer
n'importe qui sur sur les questions de
climat sur la science par exemple on va
être assez radical aussi on peut avoir
on peut être partisant de la nuance mais
parfois avoir des convictions bah
écoutez on en tout cas vraiment bonne
chance pour ne pas dire de gros mots sur
cette antenne et on aura évidemment le
plaisir de lire au café tranquillement
dimanche matin la tribune dimanche merci
Bruno jeudi merci sois Kemer vous restez
avec moi parce que vous allez réagir à
présent à la dernière séquence de
l'émission les parties pr nous affranchi
bien sûr qu'on accueille tout de
suite bonsoir les affranchis Mariette
Darry grandand notre sémiologue du
vendredi maître Bertrand Perrier
installez-vous on commence avec vous Léa
Falco c'est action planè la chronique
écolo de Léa Falco qui nous emmène du
côté des de Laurent voquier c'est ça et
des et des anes ce soir c'est ça et et
même un peu plus largement il y a une
nouvelle petite litanie qui s'installe
c'est c'est pas qu'on n pas envie de
faire la transition écologique c'est
qu'on peut pas la faire parce que c'est
trop dangereux le zan zéro artificiel
suation nette c'est dangereux pour les
habitants des campagnes l'interdiction
de location des passeports thermiques
c'est dangereux pour les locataires le
développement transport en commun c'est
dangereux pour les automobilistes bref
on s'oppose à des mesures écologiques en
prétendant protéger les gens sauf que ça
au mieux c'est fallacieux parce que
d'une part évidemment ces lois-là elles
sont pas faites pour ennuyer les maires
ou les citoyens et d'ailleurs c'est même
pas seulement des lois et des mesures de
protection de l'environnement c'est des
mécanismes qui incitent et obligent les
pouvoirs publics à penser autrement et
donc à faire des choses concrètes pour
améliorer la vie de leurs administrés ça
empêche quand même de faire un certain
nombre de choses non il y a un aspect
contraignant vous me l'accorderez
absolument alors prenons l'exemple du
zan du coup pour être très concret zéro
artificialisation net dans la bouche de
Laurent voqué ça c'est une loi
ruralicide qui est faite par les
habitants des villes contre les
habitants des campagnes mais la vraie
question derrière le zan c'est qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce futur qu'on veut pour
nos campagnes de là d'où moi je viens et
c'est même pas une campagne c'est une
ville moyenne il y a plus de commerce
dans le centre-ville parce que il y a un
grand centre commercial qui a été
construit à 20 km de là sur des terres
agricoles et l'artificialisation à tout
craint telle qu'on la pratique
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est dévitaliser
nos centr-villees c'est se rendre
toujours plus dépendant de la voiture
parce qu'il faut aller plus loin et donc
au passage de l'inflation et des pays
producteurs de pétrole c'est faire en
sorte que on perde des terres arables
précieuses en somme c'est pas quelque
chose de viable mais là où les discours
de Laurent vquier sont habiles c'est qui
nous montre ce qui est perdu
c'est-à-dire on ne peut plus
artificialiser mais parce qu'on pourrait
y gagner et ce qu'il y a à gagner c'est
du ressort des pouvoirs publics qui
doivent organiser des politiques
coordonnées refaire des centr-ville
voilà le zan ça pourrait être ça ça
pourrait être l'occasion d'avoir des
centres-villees revitalisé de moins
dépendre de la voiture partiellement de
créer peut-être pour les enfants des
voies de vélo sécurisé pour qu'ils aient
plus à dépendre de leurs parents taxi
pour aller voir leurs amis ou pour aller
au ça pourrait être l'occasion de
réorganiser des pôles industriels à
l'heure de la réindustrialisation ça
pourrait être l'occasion de repenser les
services ruraux l'accès aux services
publics dans les zones rurales et en
particulier les services médicaux qui
sont une grosse question en ce moment
donc il faut simplement se rendre compte
que ces obligations là c'est ni des
bénédictions ni des malédictions ça veut
pas dire que c'est facile pour les MRES
ruraux ou pour les élus de tout poil ça
veut pas dire que ça va marcher
facilement ce que ça veut dire c'est que
on peut saisir ces lois et ces
obligations environnementales pour en
faire autre chose que des simples lois
de protection de l'environnement et pour
faire en sorte qu'on vive mieux sauf que
ça évidemment bah c'est moins facile que
des incantations antiécologiste merci
pour ce parti prix d'un mot sois à quoi
je vous le renvoquer là à vouloir
fracturer encore plus le pays entre les
urbains et les ruraux ben je crois qu'il
cherche une voie de passage il cherche
une voie de passage médiatique il
cherche une voix de passage politique
c'est serait compliqué pour lui de de
réussir à se positionner donc là on
parle de de ruralicide ça vous rappelle
un peu le francoocide d'Éric Zemour on
essaie de d'imposer une nouvelle
grammaire dans le débat politique après
sur le fond je suis pas sûr que se
positionner comme antiécolo à tout
craint pour quelqu'un qui vise
éventuellement 2027 soit une excellente
idée on en reparlera mais de toute façon
c'est un mouvement général en Europe on
va en reparler il y a une nuit de
l'écologie à droite la semaine prochaine
Bertrand Perrier vous avez regardé la
promotion de sortie de la nouvelle Enna
il y a beaucoup de fantasme autour
toujours d'ailleurs de l'école
nationaleadministration qui a d'ailleurs
changé de nom qu'est-ce qu'on sait sur
sur cette promotion Guillaume apollinire
qui a choisi donc ses premiers postes de
sortie oui alors on rappelle que les les
gilets jaunes ont tu la peau de Lena en
quelque sorte et tout le paradoxe était
qu'il l'avait eu d'Emmanuel Macron qui
s'est en quelque sorte fait arakiri en
supprimant sa propre école qui était
devenu de façon trop visible le symbole
de toutes les dérives de
l'administration française une sorte
d'entre soi de reproduction deslites
d'endogamie qui n'était plus supportable
et donc on a effectivement supprimé Lena
pour la transformé en insp institut
national du service public alors
qu'est-ce qui change en 2021 avec l'INSP
l'INSP se veut être une école plus
ouverte avec des concours avec des
critères sociaux avec des préparations
de talent pour les boursiers des
concours plus ouverts et en amont une
formation en aval pardon une formation
plus pratique plus tournée vers des
carrières et des emplois plutôt que des
titres de sortie et évidemment
symboliquement la suppression du Grand
Corps les grands corps de l'État qui
effectivement cristallisaient tous les
fantasmes le Conseil d'État la Cour des
comptes l'Inspection des finances avant
quand on sortait dans la botte
c'est-à-dire dans les 10 12 premiers et
bien on choisissait ses corps de
contrôle ce qui était un peu paradoxal
puisque on se retrouvait tout jeune
fonctionnaire 25 30 ans à contrôlé
l'activité de préfet de diplomate bien
plus chevronné que soi-même et ce
paradoxe était devenu un peu intenable
et donc on a voulu rapprocher l'enat du
terrain les grands corps par quoi
ont-ils été remplacés alors l'idée de
Jean Castex c'était justement d'avoir
des propositions de poste à la sortie de
l'enat plus proche du terrain plus en
région en réalité ça pas vraiment été le
cas il y a eu une dizaine de postes qui
ont été créés en fait ce qui s'est
taillé la part du lon dans cette
nouvelle promotion et bien ce sont les
ministères régaliens l'économie le
travail la santé ce sont ces postes là
qui ont eu plus d'énar à leur
disposition d'pien puisque il faut plus
parler desénar maintenant et
symboliquement et bien le nouveau major
a choisi la Direction de la Sécurité
sociale on ne peut pas faire plus
opérationnel que les finan sociales et
puis dans la suite dans dans les 10
premiers beaucoup ont choisi la
préfectorale beaucoup ont choisi la
diplomatie donc vraiment des corps
extrêmement enem pris avec le réel plus
du contrôle mais de l'action et avec
cette réforme l'INSP reste attractive ou
moins oui toujours ce sont quand même
des carrières qui font encore rêver les
jeunes deè actualité pour pour Lena les
les résultats de l'admissibilité du
concours d'entrée ont été publiés cet
après-midi et donc il y avait 1200
candidats qui se sont présenter toute
filiè confondu concours externe concours
interne déjà fonctionnaire et donc il y
a 90 places il y a environ 200 admissies
qui sont ce soir à la fois contents et
anxieux et on leur souhaite bonne chance
pour les euros merci Bertrand le sens de
l'excellence à la française rien ne vous
échappe on va terminer avec vous
Mariette vous avez choisi un mot comme
chaque semaine ce mot c'est empathie oui
myiam alors je vous avoue que quand j'ai
entendu parler de cours d'empathie à
l'école maternelle j'ai j'ai quand même
eu un peu de d'ironie surtout venant de
du domaine politique qui n'est pas
vraiment réputé pour êtreès sympathique
puis je me suis dit les pauvres petits
on leur fait déjà du yoga à la crèche la
méditation de le plus jeune âge mais en
fait je pense que c'est si je fais
marcher plutôt mon esprit sologique je
pense qu'il y a là un détail signifiant
quelque chose qui nous qui nous arrête
sur notre société alors dites-nous en
quoi ce serait un signe ce mot empathie
d'abord c'est un signe de
professionnalisation des murs
c'est-à-dire que ça vient la langue des
coachs des coachs d'entreprise donc ces
coachs avec leur vocabulaire métier bah
ils entrent chez nous ils entrent dans
les familles ils entrent dans les écoles
alors bon pourquoi pas on sait
qu'aujourd'hui pour être un bon manager
en effet il faut être empathique il faut
c'est une des neuf intelligences selon
les Américains donc il y a la peut-être
la rationnelle la mathématique la
linguistique mais il y a aussi
l'empathique savoir écouter savoir être
bien donc c'est plutôt une bonne chose
que d'enseigner ça l'empathie oui je ne
sais pas oui c'est probablement une
bonne chose mais en tout cas c'est une
chose très très impliquante pour une
société si on fait de l'empathie un
savoir académique bah qu'on transmet
comme l'orthographe ou les maths il faut
savoir de quoi on parle bon alors si on
se pche sur le mot empathie en fait il
est très récent c'est un néologisme du
20e siècle créé par les psychologues
américains justement ils ont considéré
que sympathie c'est la même chose on
pourrait penser que c'est la même chose
le même radical he pate en grec ça veut
dire souffrir donc la sympathie c'est s
je souffre avec vous je souffre avec
l'autre avec et puis l'empathie le le M
dit dedans donc je vais jusque dans
l'émotion de l'autre Boris cumck
aujourd'hui dit l'enfant pour se
construire son propre monde doit aller
dans le monde de l'autre donc c'est là
où je ne sais pas si c'est bien ou mal
mais on en est là on est dans une
société où il faut apprendre aux enfants
coucou là il y a quelqu'un d'autre tu
n'es pas dans ta bulle ou aux vieux
enfants que nous sommes tous donc nous
sommes pas il ne faut pas être un ego
sur patte parce que c'est pas simplement
que c'est pas bien c'est que ça produit
une société complètement Arch isé hyper
individualisé bah qui crée de la pulsion
plus que de la réflexion et bien sûr de
la violence plutôt que du vivre ensemble
donc si vous voulez Miriam les
programmes qui à l'école nous mettent en
relation à l'autre finalement un bon
point mais c'est un vaste programme
justement c'est un programme vraiment
sociétal et fortement politique donc on
va bien voir ce que les politiques vont
en faire mais en tout cas on est devant
quelque chose de très ambitieux en tout
cas je suis pas sûr que ce soit l'école
qui doit faire ça non c'est les parents
l' bâti plutôt plutôt c'est plutôt les
plutôt les parents mais on voit bien
qu'il a il y a quand même souvent
problème avec parfois les parents et
donc est-ce que il faut partager avec
l'école quel que soit l'endroit il faut
le faire en tous les cas en tout cas il
faut le faire c'est presque
civilisationnel comme on dit beaucoup
aujourd'hui il faut quand même le vivre
ensemble traditionnel mais on demande
beaucoup à l'école quand même déjà donc
c'est ça aussi la difficulté oui aux
origines d'un mot merci et c'estes
résonance avec notre société merci
beaucoup mari d'égrand merci à vous la
Falco bonne chance à vous travaillez
bien on vous regarde et surtout on vous
lit merci Bertrand on va terminer par
cette image celle de la journaliste et
militante iranienne nargest Mohamadi qui
vient de recevoir le prix Nobel de la
paix aujourd'hui pour son combat pour la
liberté en faveur des droits des femmes
elle est en détention depuis plus d'un
an à la prison d'Avin c'est le weekend
profitez bien très belle soirée sur
LCP
[Musique]